Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the restishistory.com and join the club. That is the rest is history.com. This episode is brought to you by Hive. You know, history is full of transformations. The Romans shifted from Republic to Empire. The Tudors transformed. monasteries into country houses. And do you know what? Hive has had one of its own. Everybody knows Hive for smart thermostats, but now they've evolved into something much greater. Solar panels that
help you to power your home with clean energy. Heat pumps that pull warmth from thin air. EV charges that charge your car while you're asleep. All managed through a single app. This is all about giving people the power to transform their homes. from waste to efficiency, from dependence to control, from consumption to contribution. So history's next great transformation may not be happening in parliaments or palaces. It may be happening in your home. A quiet revolution minus guillotine. Hive. Know your power. Visit hivehome.com to find out more. Subject to survey and suitability. Hive app compatible with selected heat pumps.
For the moment, let them enjoy a calm sea, a fresh breeze and each other. The girl is pretty, and I was always sentimental. But for Jason, there are other adventures. I have not finished with Jason. Let us continue the game another day. So that, as everybody will know, was Zeus, the king of the gods. He is staring down from Mount Olympus at the Greek hero Jason. And Jason's had an extraordinary time. He sailed all the way from Greece to the distant land of Caucasus,
at the other side of the Black Sea, possibly in present-day Georgia. And he's gone there in his ship, the Argo, with the Argonauts. He has captured the fleece of a golden ram from Aetis, the king of Colchis. He has won the heart of Aetis's daughter, who is called Medea, who is a bit of a witch, literally, but very beautiful. And she has helped Jason to win the golden fleece, and it's Medea, of whom Zeus says, the girl is pretty. Poor from Zeus. And these are the very last lines of the film Jason the Argonauts, which came out in 1963, and it starred Todd Armstrong as Jason, very wooden, and Pussy Galore herself, Honour Blackman,
as Hera, the Queen of the Gods. Now, Tom, you think this is a brilliant film, don't you? I love it. I think it's a bit rubbish, but you think it's brilliant. So before we come on to the question of whether it's good or bad, there is a friend of the show who thinks it's It's not just good, but the best film ever made. Wow. Just to talk about Heera on a black man.
And she plays a key role in the film because she actually has a bit of a crush on Jason. And so she's always looking out for him throughout her adventures. And in the film, she's a kind of figurehead on the Argo with great long lashes, which she flutters at Jason. Oh, lovely. Yeah. Every so often. So incredible special effects. And Wenzu says, let us continue the game another day, he says,
that looking at Hera because they've basically been playing chess with the lives of the Argonauts moving it around the chess board on Mount Olympus. It's obvious from that that the script writers were hoping that they would get a sequel. But the problem is that moviegoers agreed with you and thought it was rubbish. Yeah. So the film completely bombed and so they never got the chance to do Jason the Argonauts part two. But Dominic, it is now widely recognized as a classic. I think that's very strong, Tom, widely recognized as a classic. And the A person who thinks it's brilliant is a friend of the show, Tom Hanks, who in 1992 compared it to Casablanca and Citizen Kane and then said, it's better than them.
It is the greatest film ever made. It hasn't struck you that Tom Hanks might have been being ironic? I don't think so. No. I don't think so because he was doing it just before the Oscars. Part of a special Lifetime Achievement Award that was being given to Ray Harry Housen. oh yeah who was the most you know the most famous special effects guru in the whole of Hollywood history so if you ever seen a film where monsters move in a slightly staccato matter
the likelihood is that ray harryhausen was behind that and his work on jason and the argonauts is widely seen now as the absolute acme of pre-cggy special effects and it's amazing for a film that was made in 1963 so special effects highlights in jason and the argonauts for those who haven't seen it, include Talos, who's a giant bronze warrior who comes to life and picks up the Argo and drops it into the sea. There are harpies who are two winged monsters who keep sweeping down and stealing food from a poor guy called Phineas, who has offended the gods. He's a blind seer, a lot of blind seers in Greek myth. He's Patrick Troughton. He's the second doctor from Doctor Who. Very underrated doctor, actually. He is. Yeah. Yes. So I thought you'd enjoy it. I mean,
He's got Honour Blackman. It's got Patrick Trouton. It's got amazing things. It's ticking all my boxes. Yeah. It's just a bad film. I'll tell you, who else it's got. Nigel Green, who was the sergeant in Zulu.
Oh, yes. Who played Heracles. Yes. And most amusingly of all, Argus, who's the guy who builds the Argo and is the captain. He's played by the guy who in a night to remember the great film about Titanic played Captain Smith. Well, he's a great act. honest, you know, if you've got to sail a ship from Greece to Colchis, Captain Smith is the last person you'd walk.
No, more slander of Captain Smith. Captain Smith completed many, many, many voyages before that unfortunate incident. He was a very reliable captain, and I just want to make it absolutely clear. Once again, I would happily sail with Captain Smith at any date you care to mention, except probably that night in 1912. Would you trust Captain Smith to get the Argo through the clashing rocks? Well, he clearly did. did. So I'll be steering wood.
Yeah, right. Clashing rocks also appear in Jason the Argonauts. And the most famous special effects in Jason and the Argonauts is skeletons that rise up out of the earth after King Aetis, who's furious because Jason's stolen the golden fleece. He sews the teeth of a monster
that Jason has slown. And these skeletons fight with Jason and two of his friends, kills two of the friends, and Jason jumps into the sea. I mean, if you haven't seen it, it's on YouTube. It's absolutely brilliant. That idea of sewing the dragon's teeth may sound familiar because people may remember that Cadmus, the Prince of Tyre, who went searching for Europa, who dressed up as a manad in the
back eye, you know, the founder of Thebes, he had also sewn a monster's teeth from which armed warriors had sprouted. And it's true that they weren't skeletons and that Cadmus, rather than fight them, had picked up a rock and thrown it into the middle of them and they'd all kind of killed each other. But it's clearly the same basic idea. And so people may be wondering, well, what's this story that was Academus in Thebes? What's it doing in Jason and the Argonauts? Isn't this just a classic example of Hollywood taking bits and pieces from different myths and stitching it all together and making a complete kind of Frankenstein's monster out of the whole thing?
But Dominic. Yeah, there's always a but. There is a but. Jason and the Argonauts, the film, is actually a very, very faithful adaptation of an epic called, the Argonautica, which was written sometime around 250 BC by a Greek poet called Apollonius of Rhodes. And this is the big source, isn't it, for the stories of the golden place? Now, one interesting thing about this which might have occurred to people listening is 250 BC
is very late. So we are now well into the Hellenistic era, aren't we? So the era following the death of Alexander the Great, and we'll come back to that later in the show. But just take us through the Argonautica, because a lot of the elements, from the film are in the poem, right? Yeah, so Talos, the giant bronze man, you know who picks up the ship, the harpies, the clashing rocks, the spartoy, the sown men, they're all in the Argonautica.
So in Apollonius's poem, it's not Aetis who sows the dragon's teeth, it's Jason. And Jason is, as he does it, is drawing a plow that is being pulled by fire-breathing bulls. And the reason for this is that it's been set as a challenge by, Aetis who doesn't want to give him the golden fleece. And so basically Aetis has said, if you draw this plough with the fire breathing bulls and you sew the dragon's teeth and you lift it all the tail, then I will give you the golden fleece. And Jason gets away with it because Medea, who is the daughter of Aetis, priestess of Hecate, the kind of the goddess of magic and witchcraft and so on, has fallen in love with him. And she gives Jason a magic ointment,
so a sports anguant which he smears all over himself and it's fire resistant so he can cope with the fire breathing bulls it has a kind of incredible cocaine style effect on his self-confidence because Jason in the epic is actually he's a bit of a wuss
so he needs a bit of a top-up he gets away with it he manages to draw the plow fire-breathing bulls they incinerate him and all of that and she's also the one who advises him to pull Cadmus's trick by throwing a stone into the middle of the sewn men.
So the story of Jason plowing the field with the fire-breathing bulls, that's a very old one. The idea that the dragon's teeth then sprout up, this is Apollonius' invention. He explains it by saying that Athena, after Cadmus had killed the dragon, took its teeth and divided them up.
Oh, nice. The Cadmus and half got given to 80s. So a bit of kind of retrospective continuity there. Yes, yes. And you can see that there is something, I think, quite Hollywood about this. Apollonius basically, I mean, you could imagine him writing for movie franchises or whatever. The Argonautica is basically the model for all the adventures of Greek heroes that you get in children's books.
Tales of Daring Doe, fights with monsters, all of that. It's not, as our previous episodes have been about, it's not about exploring the nature of the gods, plumbing the various dimensions of Dionysus or any of that. He's very, very concerned to write something that people will find page turning and exciting, interesting. And it works. I mean, it is a kind of thrilling story to read. But it's not just a thrilling story, is it? Because Apollonius, so Apollonius is a great poet, but he's also a scholar who knows loads about Greek myth. So actually, the comparison might be with a figure like J.R. Toggi, who's taking established myths and weaving them into, you know, throwing loads of elements in and creating a quest narrative that turns out to be a massive blockbuster. No?
I think he's more, I'm surprised you didn't bring it up. I think he's more like a scriptwriter for a film in the Star Wars franchise. I only did that because I know you hate, you hate Star Wars. No, I'm happy to have Star Wars introduced because I think it's quite a good parallel. Okay. You know, with Star Wars, you have a kind of pre-existing universe where there are certain characters and certain plot lines, but you can kind of mess around with it, you can introduce new characters, you can take elements from one film and put it into another. And you can do that with kind of super, He is much more like a scriptwriter for a Marvel film than he is a Greek tragedian. So he's basically taking elements from the comic books that people, you know, have grown up with and they know and love and reworking them and throwing new things in and all of that stuff, right? Well, so think of Star Wars. You had those famously terrible prequels, didn't you? I am the Princess of Nabu and I have come to negotiate a tariff reduction. I mean, unbelievably boring. But it's a prequel to the famous, you know, that kind of of iconic Star Wars. Apollonius is doing something very similar because basically he's writing
a prequel to the most famous of all Greek epics, which are homers. We see Achilles, who's going to be the hero of the Iliad as a little baby in the Argonautica. Oh my God, Anakin Skywalker. Dar Fader as a little boy. It's that kind of thing. This is the phantom menace of Greek mythology. That is the most damning thing you could possibly say about it. It's much better than that. When the Argonauts, they've got the Golden Fleece and they're sailing away from Colchis, and they take a mad route to get back to Greece along the Danube and the Rhone and end up in the Western Mediterranean. Yeah, don't go along the Rhone. That's bonkers.
By tradition is where Odysseus sailed. And so this gives Apollonius the chance to have the Argonauts meet all kinds of characters and monsters that Odysseus will go on to meet. They pass the sirens, for instance, and Odysseus gets tied to the mast so he can hear the sirens. But when the Argonauts go by, they've got Orpheus, who is the great musician who's ever lived and he plays the liar and he out sings the sirens. And also you meet Circe who in the Odyssey turns Odysseus' men into pigs and then Odysseus kind of hangs out with him. And she turns out to be Medea's aunt. So it's like, a bit like Darth Vader turning out
to be Luke's father. I'm impressed with my incredible. Amazing knowledge of Star Wars knowledge. Yeah, incredible. And so I think part of the fun of reading the Argonautica, if you know, anything about Greek myths. Seeing the familiar elements. Yeah. Yeah. It's like, oh, there's Jabba the Hut. And the Ewoks are back and his C3PO making his inevitable appearance.
You know, that's basically what it is. But having said that, for that reason, I think, just as people are kind of a bit sniffy, perhaps about Star Wars prequels, people were sniffy about the Argonautica as well. The charge that Apollonius was a scavenger and a plagiarist was one that followed him throughout his career. Traditionally, it is said that. And I knew that your hackles always arise when it is said that. Yeah. So it didn't. Yeah. But let's say for now that this is genuinely happened. He had as his critic the most admired and celebrated poet of the age who was a guy called Callimachus. Right. And Apollonius is writing, you know, an epic. It's full of monsters and so on.
Calimachus is writing very delicate, recondite poems. So if Apollonius is a scriptwriter for a Star Wars prequel, Colimachus is more like T.S. Eliot or Emily Dickinson. Or if he's working in cinema, he's making little art house face. 10 minutes long. Yes. And the reason for this is very self-conscious, because we are no longer living in an age of epic. And that trying to be Homer is mad, you know, we can never do it.
the circumstances that were germane in Homer's age have completely vanished. You cannot help if you're going to try and write a Homeric epic, it will be pastiche, it will be kind of bombastic, it'll be kind of meretricious trash. Callimachus' nickname for Apollonius seems to have been the ibis, and this is a bird that could be seen everywhere in Egypt, very common. And it's always fascinated Greek writers for reasons that Peter Green, in his tremendous book on the Hellenistic period, from Alexander to Actium. I chose that as one of my favorite history books from Alexander to Actium.
It's like 6,000 pages long. Peter Green lived to the age of 200, didn't he? We're still writing books like when other people have been long dead. Brilliant historian. And very, very entertainingly written. So he explains why the ibis fascinated Greek writers. So this is Peter Green. The ibis was a foul feeder of gluttonous and indiscriminate veracity,
scavenging any kind of filth or carrion. It was also popularly believed to offset its diet by giving itself water enemers and colonic irrigation per annum with its own beak. Besides copulating orally, nesting in date palms to avoid cats and having a gut over 40 yards long
and he then goes on to quote the geographer Strabo, who was writing in the reign of Augustus, omnivorous and unclean, the ibis is only with difficulty kept away from things that are clean themselves and alien to all defilement. So in other words, if we're to trust the tradition that Colimachus hated Apollonius, by comparing Apollonius to an ibis, he's essentially attacking
the Argonautica not just as a kind of, you know, a mess of scavenged bits of trash, but for poisoning the ancient pure springs of myth. And again, I think that is very like a kind of highbrow Critic of a Hollywood blockbuster. It's a Guardian film writer saying there are too many Marvel films and people should be watching more Ingmar Bergman. Exactly. That's essentially what he's saying. And I think, you know, on one level,
you can see where Callimachus is coming from because the story of the Argonauts, I mean, it does draw on the foundational springs of Greek myth. Homer doesn't mention Medea, but he does specify that Circe was sister to Aetis. So, in fact, it wasn't Apollonius' invention that Medea was Ursi's niece. And equally, he doesn't mention the golden fleece, but he does mention Jason and specifically the clashing rocks.
So in the Odyssey, when Circe is warning Odysseus about the clashing rocks and says, you know, avoid them at all cost. Circe tells him that the Argo is the only ship that had ever passed through them. So to quote the Odyssey, the swells would have hurled her too against those gigantic rocks, had Hera not sent her on through, since Jason was dear to her. So pussy galore stepping in to save Jason. The rest of Apollonius' epic is culled from kind of various poets. So Hesiod is there. There's another poet from Thebes called Pinder,
who wrote in the 5th century BC, and in Athens, Euripides, a friend of the show, author of the Bacchi, who we talked about in the previous episode. So Pinder, we know from him that the story had begun with this absolutely kind of classic fairy tale, which revolves around a wicked stepmother who's out to get the two children of the king of Thessaly, who are called Frixus and Heli. And the brother and sister, Frixus and Heli, they escape on a flying ram with a golden fleece. And the ram takes off from Thessaly, flies over the Aegean, flies over the Hellespont. and there's a disaster because
Ellie hasn't got her seatbelt on and slips off and drowns in the stretch of water below. Yeah, hence the name. Hence the name, the Hellespon. But Frixus gets, he crosses the Black Sea, safely lands in Colchis and is given shelter by Aetis
and when the flying golden ram dies, the fleece brings prosperity to Aetis' kingdom and so he hangs it on a tree in a sacred grove where it is looked after by a dragon and the dragon the great serpent wraps its coils
around the tree. So this is all very familiar from the ladybird book of the Jason the Argonauts that I read when I was about five. And also I see that the rest of the details where Jason goes to get the fleece.
They're also in the ladybird book and they're from Pindar too. Absolutely classic kind of Greek myth isn't it? His father, what was his going? Aeson, the king of, yeah, Iolcos. He's been kicked out by his uncle,
Pilius, when Jason was a baby. And Jason, obviously, it's always the way he's been raised by a kind of wise old sage who is called Chiron and happens to be a centaur. Happens to be a centaur. But like, what's his name? The little gnome thing with a stupid voice. Oh, come on.
Are you talking about Yoda? Yoda. Yoda. So, yeah, so Chiron is the Yoda. Ignorant to Star Wars are you, Tom Holland? Am I? That doesn't work, doesn't it. No.
Luke doesn't speak in the saying Yoda's voice to Yoda. Come on. No, true. Okay. All right. So, meanwhile, back in Ayolcos, Pilius, there's obviously a prophecy. I mean, there's always a prophecy. And he's been worn to beware a man with one sandal.
And Jason, he's been instructed by Chiron past his A-levels. And so now it's time for him to set off to Iolkos. He's going along, and there's an old woman, there's a, swollen river. The old woman can't get across the river. So Jason gives her a piggyback. At the far side, the old woman transforms into Hera. And this is why Hera from this point on is Jason's a great patron. Bart Dominic, while he's been crossing the river, what do you think's happened to his footwear? Oh, his sandal has come off, hasn't it? Very famous. Yeah. Sandal has come off. Yes. So he turns up and Peleus sees this new arrival and realizes, oh my God, his trouble. So he comes up
with a brilliant scheme, which is that he tells Jason, look, I will give you the throne, but first of all, I really think that you should go to Colchis and get the golden fleece. And people may be wondering, well, that's, you know, why would Jason do that? And Pius comes up with three unanswerable reasons. The first of these is that the ghost of frixus demands it, say the little boy. Yeah, don't argue with him. The second is an oracle has urged it. So you can't argue with that.
And the third is that just as the golden fleece has brought. peace and prosperity to Colchis. So if it gets stolen, then that peace and prosperity will be brought to Ayolcus. So unanswerable. Jason says, yeah, fine, whatever. And Peleus swears solemn vow that he will give Jason the throne if he comes back with the golden fleece. So to quote Pindar, so this was their agreement, and then they parted. And at once Jason ordered heralds everywhere to proclaim that a great voyage was to be made. And on the question of the voyage, so I remember Michael Wood did a TV series and Michael Wood has been on our show,
great TV historian, called In Search of Myths and Heroes and he went on this great sort of expedition to Georgia on the other side of the Black Sea and he was trying to sort of uncover the roots of the golden fleece myth and he was sort of arguing you know the roots lie in memories
of Greek voyages out into the unknown across the Black Sea to a land that maybe had gold or some kinds of riches or who knows. There is a sense, isn't there, among historians and scholars, that the story of Jason the Golden Fleece does reflect a kind of historical reality,
which is, what would you call it, the Greek Age of Expiration? Yeah, a sense of... Colonization. Yeah, going out... I mean, Greeks obviously go to the Crimea, don't they? They do go across the Black Sea to the far side. When is that time period?
Because that must have been centuries distant by the time that people like... Well, certainly by the time Apollonius was writing. Eighth, seven centuries. Right. I mean, into the sixth century, and it's about a process of discovery, and they are venturing out into seas where you could well believe that you've come across clashing rocks or monsters or sirens or whatever. So whether you're going westwards or eastwards. So it's a bit like
the stories told by Vikings sailing off into the Atlantic or down the great rivers through Russia. But the problem, and this is, I think, why Callimachus has a point, is that by 250, BC. I mean, everybody knows what the Mediterranean and the Black Sea are like. No one could conceivably believe that there are monsters there. And so that, I think, is why Apollonius sends the Argonauts into kind of Middle Europa. Oh, the Rhone and whatnot. Yeah, because generally people don't know what's going on there. Right. So more opportunity for monsters. So the one character who everybody remembers Jason the Golden Fleece, the hypnotic figure of Medea, the beautiful sorceress who helps Jason, but then obviously things go very, very badly wrong for them as a
couple. Where does she come from? Does she come from Pindar as well? Yes. So Pindar provides Apollonius with the outline of her story. And in Pindor's account, Madera is a very heroic figure, so as in the film, actually, and her aid is crucial to Jason's success. He wouldn't have been able to win the golden fleece without her. Aphrodite Pindar says, you know, casts a spell of love over her. And in Apollonius' version, it's ridiculous. Aphrodite gets Eros, her son, to shoot an arrow. And Eros is like the kind of most annoying. It's like scrappy do. He's like a kind of infuriating child friendly character. It's just terrible. Like Jar Jar Binks. Yes. He's the Jar Jajar Binks of Greek epic poetry. And Medea is,
she's got this arrow of love embedded in her heart. It leads her to basically portray her. father give Jason the magic ointment that enables him to, you know, harness the bulls and pep up his confidence. And also Medea helps him to kill the dragon that's been guarding the golden feast. She has another ointment, puts it in the dragon's eyes and the dragon falls asleep, and Jason then kills it. And on the long voyage back, she provides the Argonauts with magic and prophecy. That basically is the outline that Pinder gives Apollonius and Apollonius kind of sticks to it. There is another much more famous literary portrayal of Medea that Apollonius had inherited and had to negotiate.
And this comes from Euripides. Yeah, we know that Euripides loves a really dark play. And he loves a murderous woman. And in Euripides' play about Medea, she is portrayed in a very dark light. And she is guilty of assorted crime. So in the backstory, she, as the Argonauts escape, she's taken her brother with her in one account. As Iyte's fleet is closing in on the Argonauts,
she chops her brother up into two people. and throws it out into the sea. Such a weird and unsettling detail. So Aetis has to stop to pick up the bits. Or in another account, the brother is leading the pursuit and Medea kills him. When they get back to Thessaly, Pilias predictably does not hand over the throne. So Medea eliminates him. And she does it in a kind of brilliantly complicated way.
She gets Pilius's daughters. And she says, look, I have incredible powers of sorcery. Your father is very, very elderly. I can make him much younger. Look, and she bruise up a potion in a cauldron, and she gets an aged ram, and she slits the throat of the ram, and then she chops the ram up into little bits. This is obviously something the Medea's really into, is chopping up bodies. And she chucks all the portions of the ram into the cauldron. And there's kind of shimmering and a flash. And then a minute later, the ram pops out, and it's now a baby lamb, kind of had all its youth restored to it. And she says, if you do this to your father, then I'll be able to do the same. And so Peles's daughter's get their father, slit his throat, chop him into bits, chuck him into the cauldron, and nothing happens. And that's the end of Pileas.
So Jason then can become king of Ioccus and Thessaly. And you'd think that he'd be very grateful to Medea. But by this point, Jason is thinking, you know, she's a bit of a nightmare. She's just, you know, endlessly chopping people up. And faithfully, in Euripides version, he dumps Medea for a princess called Glauque, who's the princess of Corinth. and so Medea doesn't take this lying down and she sends Glauque a poisoned dress and crown and Glauque puts it on and vanishes in a puff of smoke and Medea then goes off
kills the two sons that she's had by Jason thereby denying him any male heirs and flies off in a chariot drawn by dragons and goes to Athens she's a piece of work isn't she She's the Mary Lincoln of Greek mythology, Tom. So harsh. So hard. I hope the people on the Reddit enjoy that one. Continue. Basically, Euripides' influence is so strong.
He's become such a kind of classic by this point, that this is now the canonical understanding of Medea. But it doesn't really suit Apollonius' purposes. I mean, it's too bloodstained, too murderous. And so essentially he kind of slightly whitewashes that out. I mean, that is so Hollywood. You know, oh, we want to take it out. It's like the, yeah, it's like the Adam West Batman.
It's, you know, all the dark, light stuff. I'm just going to say it first before the listeners do. There's a lot of ludicrous parallels being made in this episode. I think it's not. But we lean into it. We love it. Euripides, Sophocles, the Great Tragedians, they have become classics. And they have put later poets in their shadow.
And Apollonius, you know, has this anxiety of influence. He's always conscious of it. And that is really Kalimachus' point is that you can't write something fresh about Medea because we have these, you know, the Euripides' portrait means that you're always going to be operating in its shadow. And the only thing that Apollonis can do basically is to ignore that, set it aside. And there's a kind of parallel, I think, in which the way that poets in, say, you know, 250 BC are in the shadow of a vanished greatness, literary greatness.
politically Athens is slightly similar because Athens now in 250 BC stands in the shadows of empires that are vastly greater than the empire that the Athenians had run in the 5th century and the independence of Athens and of all the other Greek city states has effectively been snuffed out and Dominic I mean you know you know by whom yeah no one loves this more than I do
I love to see the Athenians get a kicking from Macedon so Philip of Macedon started it didn't he in 338 he smashed the Athenians and the Thebans and then four years later Alexander the Great one of the very top friends of the rest is history he'd gone off on his I think what we described as a gap here that got out of control conquering the Persian Empire going off to Afghanistan
dressing up in his foreign clothing Exactly exactly taking proscenesis adopting Persian customs Goes off to Central Asia goes off to India and then he dies in 3-2-3 and his empire is carved up and it's always sort of said or it fragmented into these pitiful little success estates
but actually those success of states are pretty powerful and rich empires the Sunucid Empire the Ptolemaic Empire and I guess the most glamorous certainly for me and it's the place when people say where would you go
if you had a time machine a classic Restis History Club question Alexandria it's Alexandria rather than Athens that is the real metropolis in this period isn't it the city of culture, of science. It's a mega city.
Yeah. Yeah. Obviously, it's founded by Alexander, named after him with Alexander's customary modesty. And the thing about Alexandria, as opposed to Athens or Thebes, with their kind of ancient stories about their beginnings and their ancient relations with the gods and heroes,
is that on the site of Alexandria, before Alexander arrived there, there had been nothing. There was only kind of marshes and sea birds. The St. Petersburg of North Africa. Yeah. No temple.
no festivals and crucially no myths. And so then there's an obvious question. What do the ancient gods mean in a city where everyone is an immigrant? What relevance do these ancient Greek poems now have? And I think that that's what the argument between Climachus and Apollonius is all about. Neither of them come from Greece, old Greece. Climachus had moved there from Cyrene, which is a city in what's now Libya. And Apollonius himself, despite his name, Apollonius of Rhodes, seems actually to have been born in Alexandria. and he was called off-roads because he liked visiting there. Can Alexandria be a place?
What role does myth have in such a city? And I think that Callimachus' charge against Apollonius, therefore, is very clear and not unjustified, which is that if you're going to write an ancient epic and you are doing so as a citizen of a Parvenu megacity like Alexandria, then you can't help but be kind of vulgar and meretricious. And I suppose it's slightly, again, like, you know, high-bramble. British attitudes towards American films. Right, exactly. But it's also, interestingly, it mirrors the criticism that historians for a long time
have actually made of the Hellenistic era, haven't they? Historians and critics, really since the 19th century, you've been holding up Greece, the classical age of Greece as the model, have then said, oh, and what came next was vulgar and meretricious and a bit of a pastiche? Yeah. And, I mean, that's the classic criticism of Hellenistic culture. But just to reiterate, I mean, that is the criticism that Callimachus is making, who is probably the greatest poet. He's anticipating it, yeah.
Calimachus is looking back to Athens and to Homer as the true golden age of Greek literature. Yeah. And, you know, we do the same by and large. Yeah. That tends to be the assumption. You do. I actually love the Hellenistic era. I prefer to Pasco-Greece.
I love the Hellenistic era too, but I can recognize. that there is a point to Kalimachus's criticism that it is slightly ursats. Because you don't like multiculturalism like I do, Tom. No, Dominic. There is an Erzatz quality to trying to write an epic about a corner of the world that
everyone knows is there and saying that it's full of monsters. But to stick up for Apollonius, Apollonius obviously thinks that it's an entirely legitimate what he's doing because otherwise he wouldn't write his epic. Of course. And he thinks that Calimachus is the idiot. So like you. And he wrote this one,
line poem, which is kind of structured like an entry in an encyclopedia. And he sums up Klimachus as trash, a cheap joke, a blockhead. I love Apollonius. I think it sounds brilliant. That's exactly what I would do. And I think that his defense of the Argonautica wouldn't just have been that it's, you know, a thrilling page turner. What's wrong with a thrilling page turner? You know, they're great. But also he would say he's doing something much more with it. And specifically, what he is doing, he would say, I think, is that he is adapting myth. You know, this great inheritance of the stories of the gods and the heroes to the age of Alexander's successors, which is an age of global horizons, of kings who claim to be gods, and of teeming
megacities that had not existed when, you know, Sophocles, let alone Homer was writing their masterpieces. All right. Well, let's take a break, Tom. And then when we come back after the break, let's look or talk about Alexander and his influence on what we've come to call Greek mythology. And let's look at what happens to this corpus of Greek stories and the way the Greeks understand the supernatural in the wake of Alexander's conquests.
This episode is brought to you by Uber. Now, do you know that feeling when someone shows up for you when you need it most? We all need that sometimes, and Uber knows it. Uber isn't just a ride or a meal delivered, it's showing up no matter what. Like for your long distance friends, bringing soup when they're sick, sending flowers when they're down. When it really matters, whatever it is, you show up. Where there's a will, we're on our way. Uber, on our way. Download the app today.
Welcome back to. the rest is history. Now, we promised you Alexander the Great. Alexander the Great, of course, was famously devoted to the stories of Greek myth and legend. So there's a story, isn't there, that he travels with a copy of the Iliad, a sort of very fancy folio society edition of the Iliad that he puts under his pillow. And he clearly is a very God-fearing or God's-fearing man, because when he crosses the Hellers-Pond, for example, he builds an altar to the the 12 Olympians. And he was obsessed particularly with Achilles. I mean, he thinks of himself and his friend Hefeistian as the modern day Achilles and Patroclus. And he takes all this
incredibly seriously, doesn't he, Tom? He does. He comes to think that he's literally the son of Zeus. Yeah. He goes to the Oracle of Siwa. Yeah. When he reaches what's now Afghanistan, he sees traces all around him of Dionysus, who was supposed to have traveled there many, many centuries before. So he sees kind of stone burial heaps that are covered with ivy and Ivy was sacred to Dionysus and so Alexander assumes that these were boundary stones that have been set up by the god. Alexander's ambition is to go even further than Dionysus. So to quote Arrian, the Roman historian writing in the second century AD, he confidently expected his troops would join him in this done as it would be in imitation of Dionysus's achievements. But Dominic, that doesn't happen,
does it? No, so he's never defeated, but he's defeated by his own men in India on the river Hyphasis. They force him to turn back in three, two, six. Yet again, he built an altar to the gods. I mean, Alexander, he just, he loves doing two things, basically founding cities called Alexandria, building altars. And then he goes back to Babylon. And three years later, he's dead in Babylon, probably in malaria, possibly a poison. We can't be sure. Or is he, Tom? Is he dead? So Alexander is obviously angling to be worshipped as a god, and this is a conceit that is treated with absolute contempt by, say, the Athenians. I mean, they see this as an example of the insane megalomania. But the thing is, it doesn't actually take long for the Athenians to hail one of Alexander's successors in person as a god. So not long after Alexander's death, only a few decades in 2.95, you have this Macedonian strong man called Demetrius the Bess. Sieger, which I always thought it's a brilliant subricate, yeah. Polyoketes, isn't it? Yeah. Yeah. And he comes to Athens and occupies it, and he addresses the Athenians in the theatre of Dionysus, where the tragedies have been staged. And he appears there as though he is, you know, a hero or maybe even a god, kind of deus ex machina appearing there. And four years later, he comes back to Athens and he's overtly greeted as though he were Dionysus, as though, you know, he has appeared, as though it's the amphisteria. And he's accompanied. And he's a need into Athens by dancers carrying giant fallacies. And the Athenians hail him with this kind of
poem. The other gods are far distant or have no ears or do not exist or ignore us. But we can see before us, you are not made of stone or wood. No, you are real. And they hail Demetrius as Sota, as saviour, and they allow him to live with his mistress in a back room of the Parthenon up on the Acropolis, the great temple to Athena on the Acropolis, and Demetrius very modestly begins to refer to Athena as his sister. And that's just not his own ego, right? Because this is becoming a trend across the Hellenistic world. And I'm wondering, a lot of this must come from Egypt, from the Ptolemies, who are being worshipped as gods. And actually, Ptolemy the first, calls himself Sota, doesn't he, the Savior? So this is becoming a trend for kings,
would you say, across the Hellenistic era, to identify themselves of the gods? And I think you're right that it's part of a kind of cultural soup, but I think it's also reflecting a sense that the Olympians are not there for people in their kind of hour of need, that the old rituals and cults that had seemed to keep Athens in the favor of the gods are no longer functioning. The corollary of this in turn is a kind of growing public skepticism among intellectuals about the Olympians full stop. So there is one book in particular that becomes an absolute bestseller in exactly this period. And you can see why, when I tell you what it's seem is, it's written by a philosopher called Euhmerus. And he comes up with a kind of very novel explanation for the ancient myths. He's kind of Graham Hancock of the ancient world. And he wrote that this book is called the Sacred Register.
And in it, Eucharist claims that he'd been sent on a diplomatic mission by one of the Macedonians to an island in the Indian Ocean. And there he had found an inscription written in hieroglyphics. And this is the Sacred Register. So it's very Graham Hancock. And the Sacred Register reveals a bombshell truth, which is that Zeus hadn't been a god at all. He'd been a mortal king of Crete, who after his death had come to be worshipped as a god,
and that this was true of all the other Olympians as well. They were all been mortals, and they'd been raised up to the heavens. And the popularity of this thesis suggests just how large a market it there has come to be by the third century BC for works of philosophy, that it's no longer the kind of researche habit that has been under Plato, it's becoming kind of becoming part of the mainstream. So actually to go back to the last episode where we were talking about philosophers establishing themselves in opposition to poets and storytellers, initially they were out there
in their little, you know, their academy outside the city, but their ideas have clearly percolated more deeply over the centuries, and now would it be an exaggeration to say that by and large now in the Hellenistic era, if you are a self-respecting intellectual, in other words, in other words, if you're the kind of person who's hanging around to the museum in Alexandria, you are skeptical about the stories of the Olympians and you say, come on, this stuff is obviously rubbish. Yeah. There aren't people with the heads of this and turning themselves into eagles and sleeping
with women. That's obviously rubbish. Yes, I think it is. And again, I mean, it's like, you know, all comparisons. have their problems. But perhaps there's a slight element of the way in which most intellectuals would be embarrassed to say that they believe that God became a baby and was born from a virgin, that kind of thing. Yeah. Yep. Yep. Yeah. And a bit like with the rejection of institutional Christianity today by intellectuals, the rejection of the stories told of the Olympian gods
by intellectuals in the Hellenistic world is often cast as a kind of triumph of reason over superstition and of self-examination over blind faith. But this itself is a myth because just as intellectuals today who think that they have rejected, you know, the superstitions of the past actually are merely propagating new forms of that superstition. So you can see in the Hellenistic world, the rejection of what philosophers come to cast as superstition breeds its own superstitions. Okay. Interesting.
So I, and I would say that what is happening in the Hellenistic world is that kind of notions of the supernatural that have been appropriate to a world of small city states is now being adapted to a kind of vast, globalized one with megacities. Right. The classic example of what this meant in practice, a guy called Epicurus, who is the son of Athenian settlers on Samos. He'd been a boy back when. Alexander had crossed the Hellespont, and he ends up in Athens, where he teaches a vision of
the universe that is very atomistic. He teaches that everything is made up of atoms. And in due course, this will make him a great hero of re thinkers and skeptics in the Enlightenment. But Epicurus is absolutely not an atheist, and he is still less a kind of rationalist. He did believe in gods. it's just that the gods he believed in were gods who didn't intervene in human affairs and did not control the destiny of the world and his interest in the natural world so all this kind of stuff about atoms and things
it's not because he's some kind of proto-scientist that is absolutely not what Epicurus is about to this day there are rationalists who say oh Epicurus he's brilliant you know he's a kind of proto-scient he's the opposite the only reason Epicurus has for researching the nature of things is to appreciate the pointlessness of believing in myths. And this is because in turn, it will lead to the state of tranquility atyxia in Greek
that Epicurus sees as being the ultimate goal of existence. So effectively what he's doing is saying turn on, tune in, drop out. It's a completely radical rejection of the assumptions of classical Athens. And that's why there's a lot of hostility towards Epicurus. but it's not like he's saying go out and become a, you know, invent nuclear physics or something like that. He's basically, I mean, basically, he's less Richard Dawkins. He's much more than Maharishi. Right.
He's somebody who says sort of ignore all the silly rituals and stuff of the stuffy squares. What we need to, he's like the kind of person who drops out to become a Buddhist in the 1960s. Is that basically what it is? Yeah. Well, you know, Buddhism is a kind of noble ancient tradition. There's a strong element of the charlatan about. Epicurus. So he's like somebody talking about New Age crystals,
that kind of thing. He's a profound a philosopher than that. I mean, there are Epicureans to this day who will not like that categorization. You know, so all the papy scrolls in Herculaneum that are starting to be deciphered now are by Epicureans, which is slightly frustrating.
But Epicureus himself, I mean, there are definite qualities of, you know, the guru. So he sets up effectively a commune in Athens, which is funded by his wealthy admirers. Epicurus is not remotely in favour of allowing his followers to think for themselves. So his dictum is always act always as though Epicurus is watching. So he's a kind of big brother. Right. And his admirers, while he's alive, call him the leader. And then when he
dies, they call him Sota, saviour. God. So he really is like a cult leader. You know, this is an age where people are looking for a savior. And when he dies, I mean, considering that Epicurus had absolutely rejected the notion of interventionist gods, I mean, Epicurus is, you know, he's he's remembered very much like an interventionist god so he while he was alive he'd referred to his body as being something holy um he demanded the first fruits from his followers so that's you know the first the first fruits for the harvest which is conventionally what you pay to the Olympian gods and then after his death they hold commemorative feasts so he's kind of you know it's looking back to the Olympian gods it's looking forward to the kind of the way that
Christians will commemorate Christ epicurus is not an embodiment of enlightened rationalism, I think it's fair to say. And, you know, there's that famous comment Chesterton makes that, and you can adapt it, that when the Greeks choose not to believe in the Olympians, it's not that they don't believe in, you know, they don't believe in nothing. They become capable of believing in anything, basically. So to go back to Jason the Argonaut, so what that's reflecting, therefore, is an age where there's a genuine kind of a massive flux of ideas, where the old institutions,
the old sort of rituals and assumptions have lost some of their power over people and people are picking and choosing much more as they will do in like 1970s America or something. They're questing. Yes, exactly. They're searching for meaning. Yes, exactly.
So kind of hanging out in the garden and dropping out is one option. There's another option which is hinted at quite strongly in Eucharist's book because Eucharist, I mean, he's not an atheist either. He thinks that the Olympians were originally more but he does think that there are gods, but he thinks that the gods are planets. And this is another thing that is obviously influenced by Egyptian, Babylonian traditions,
you know, the Greek kings of Egypt and of, you know, the Seleukids, they have access to this kind of very, very ancient astronomical, astrological inheritance. And so this is a way in which the Olympians actually kind of make a return for Greek intellectuals, is that the planets come to be identified with the Greek gods. So the swiftest planet is the planet that comes to be called Hermes, the messenger of the gods, and the Romans call Mercury. And we still call it Mercury to this day. The brightest, most beautiful planet, Aphrodite, aka Venus.
The bloodiest planet, the planet that's the color of blood, is Ares, the god of war, or Mars. And of course, the largest planet, that's the king of the gods, Zeus, or as we call it Jupiter. But the thing is that the rule of these planetary Olympians is much, much more tyrannical than the rule of the traditional Olympian gods had been because the planets can't be swayed by festivals or by, you know, sacrifices or anything like that. They're completely indifferent.
They're chill. The doom that's written in the stars if you believe in astrology is something that you can't escape. And there's always been an element of fatalism. There's always been an element of fatalism in the Greek understanding of the divine and whatnot, hasn't there? But it's become more pronounced now, would you say? I think if you believe that your fate is locked into the stars, all you can do, the best you can do is to try and learn what it is
by becoming a massive kind of astrology fan. But there is an even bleaker possibility, which also becomes very widespread in this period, that there is no order at all, and that the greatest of all gods is Taiki, so Greek for fate for fortune and that there is therefore you know there's no pattern there there's no logos there's no possibility of fathoming an order in the universe because there isn't one so an Athenian poet put it in kind of very devastating terms it's not Logos which guides
the affairs of mortals but Taiki so you were saying this is an age where people are looking around for answers and solutions and some of these answers and solutions are very bleak so Now, I think astrology is very bleak. It tells you what's going to happen. There's nothing you can do to affect it. And if you think that that Taiki is the goddess that controls everything, then a philosopher sums it up well. Her influence on our lives is as beyond computation
as the manifestations of her power are unpredictable. And yet, so we've been talking about philosophers, but what do the people in the streets of Athens or Alexandria, the taverns in the marketplaces, is what do they think? Because there's always a danger when we're talking about belief that we over-emphasise the importance of that minority of people who really, really care about these things and talk about them a lot.
But most people, of course, don't. They're interested in the price of bread or whatever. So Jason and the Argonauts would not have been so successful, presumably, unless there were loads of punters who loved this kind of thing and who genuinely thought that it had meaning, presumably. The old rituals that had sustained the independent Greek city states carry on even though they're no longer independent. And for some, you know, it becomes like the equivalent of the trooping of the color
or Bastille Day. I mean, that's kind of the limit of it. But I think for lots of people, they do continue to feel that the gods are imminent and that by practicing these rituals and these festivals, they are in communion with the gods. But I think also there are intellectuals who clearly miss the gods who love them. And Apollonius would be representative of that. Apollonius, when he writes the Argonautica, is not doing it as a hick. He's not doing it as someone who doesn't understand exactly what he's doing,
because he, like Callimachus, is a very, very great scholar. And they are both employed in the greatest of all the kind of research institutes that the Hellenistic period throws up, and we've done an episode on it, namely the Library of Alexandria. So Calimachus is the guy, as well as writing Recondite poetry. He's drawn up the catalogue of the library, you know, absolutely massive product. And Apollonius is an academic specialist on Homer. So when he's writing an epic on the Homeric model, he knows what he's talking about.
He's been involved drawing up the kind of the canonical text of Homer, which is something that scholars in Alexandria are really keen on doing it. He does it so well that he ends up becoming the chief librarian of Alexandria and he pips, Kalimachus to the job. And so that's why although there is skepticism among some scholars about the idea of this literary rivalry between the two men, I think there was. because I think that's exactly the kind of thing that would have probably, you know, they would have absolutely hated each other. And so you can see that the Argonautica, even though it's a rollic and good read and tremendous entertainment, it is also something else. It is a study, a logos of myths. So it is a mythologia. Right. And so what is happening in Alexandria with people like Apollonius is that myth is becoming mythology. So just distinguish for us what you mean by the
difference in myth and mythology. So is the difference maybe that mythology is more self-conscious and nostalgic and backward-looking, do you think? It's the study of myths. Right. It's the telling of myths with an awareness of their backstory and that you were doing it in a kind of a literary or scholarly manner. So, you know, a children's book is a collection, you know, is a work of mythology or telling mythology. The writer doesn't believe any of it is drawing kind of various elements and putting them together to tell a good story. But at its highest level, it results in extraordinary works of literature. And this is how the myths pass into the bloodstream of European culture. So the Romans are writing mythology. So Virgil, when he adapts Homer
to tell this great epic drawing on stories of the Trojan War and the Odyssey that explains the beginning, the origins of Rome, the aneerneed is a work of mythology. Right. Virgil doesn't think it's real. Virgil is, there's a slight maybe a tiny bit of an antiquarian element to it almost. There is an antiquarian element. I mean, whether he thinks it's real or not as complicated question. But it's not summing up myth for the Romans in the way that Homer defines myth for the Greeks. And you have Ovid as well, who writes this great collection of stories of transformations, metamorphoses,
or writers and artists through the Middle Ages, the Renaissance into the modern period, is the great storehouse of Greek myth. It's the storehouse that Shakespeare draws on, Titian, Jason the Ogonauts, children's, you know, Percy Jackson, all of that. That's how the myths endure. Because if you have mythology, you have myth.
The myth is embedded within the mythology. But also, don't they endure because, you know, so many, I know you hate using the word, religion, but I'm just going to use it very loosely. So many ancient religions were defined through ritual, through ritual, through practice. But what makes the Greek myths form of a better word distinctive is their stories. They began as poems. And that that's why they endure in a way that the stories of the Babylonians or even the Egyptians, you know, they seem unsatisfying to us in a way that the Greek myths aren't because they were ritualistic rather than literary. The Greek myths were
always literary. Yeah, I think that's absolutely right. And I think that's why they appeal to children and they appeal to, you know, famous intellectuals like Nietzsche and Freud. And they've served as an inspiration to great writers and artists in a way that no other mythology has done. Yeah. And they continue to this day. And that's why we can do a series on Greek myths. Possibly the Norse myths, because they also have come down to us purely as stories rather than as performance or ritual. But I think that's slightly different because the Greek myths are coming from the molten heart of belief. The Norse epics are written long after the belief in the gods. And so they have all kinds of contaminations.
That explains their potency. There is a drawback, though, which is that because it's mediated for us by mythology, by people who are studying it in a kind of slightly absolute. way. And because over the course of the generations and the centuries, it's been perpetuated by people who do not believe any of it at all. And that's the inheritance that we get. It is difficult for us because our assumptions tend to be materialist and Christian. You know, we have kind of a cultural overlay. It is difficult for us to get back into the mindset of the Greeks themselves, to get back into the age of Sophocles and Euripides and still more of Homer. But I think, you cannot properly understand the Greeks without trying to imagine yourself in a world
where the gods are the primary actors in the life of the various Greek cities and in the cosmos more generally, because it's only then that we can properly see how the Greeks saw themselves. Yeah. And that's the huge, I increasingly think that about the classical period of Greece and the centuries before it is that the challenges. to try and imagine yourself back into a world where you can escape the mythology and reenter a world of myth, to put it like that. Very nice. Very nice way to sum it up, Tom.
But actually, an even better way would be for me to ask you, your favorite myth, top myth. My favorite myth was always the Odyssey. Really? Yeah, I always loved the Odyssey because it was my gateway drug. Yeah, okay, fair enough. And I would love to do an episode at some point on The Odyssey. We did one with Daniel Mandelson, but that's only for the club members, and club members can get it at the rest of history.com.
But those who don't, maybe we could do one for the general listener. I think we should absolutely do one for the general listener. To give people an insight into the ruthless way in which we conduct our affairs, I think we should do that when Christopher Nolan's film at The Odyssey comes out. Yeah, let's do that. I think we should do a series that Restor's history subscribers will be able to hear first. That's a very good plan. Very good plan.
Now you see the way. People get a little glimpse behind the curtain and they see the way in which we plan these things with no regard to commercial motives whatsoever. We're like the Olympians, aren't we? Yeah. Kind of drawing up rules and creatures of whim, but also of power. Dominic, before we go, you ask me my favorite Greek myth. That's yours. Theseus.
Because that was my gateway. That was the first one I read, Thetius and the, and going at the labyrinth, fighting the minor tour and all that. I loved all that. The black sails. We can do one on Crete as well. Crete. Well, Crete, shawdy, is a series waiting to happen. It is.
Right. It is basically the episode has turned into a scheduling meeting, which is lovely. We're back, aren't we, with an episode on someone who's very into the classics, namely Enoch Powell. Wow. That's a, that's a good segue. That's a thrilling transition, isn't it? And then after that, we've got a woman who is very into acting out the Greek myths, namely Emma Hamilton, who goes on to become Nelson's great paramour. And then after that, we have the return.
of the Admiral himself, Nelson. I can't wait. Cannot wait. Right, and that bumshall, thank you so much, Tom. That was absolutely fascinating, brilliant. A tour de force. We haven't had a tour de force for a while,
but now we've had a really good one. Brilliant. Thank you. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.